when we explored Newton's first law we
saw that an object will maintain its
velocity unless it's acted on by some
unbalanced force but we did not explore
in Newton's first law is exactly what is
the relationship between the unbalanced
force and the velocity and that's what
we're going to look into in this video
and before I go into possible theories
between how these are related let's
introduce another idea let's just maybe
every object has associated with it some
value and I'll call that quantity m and
that's a measure of how resistant that
object is to a change in velocity so
resistance resistance to change change
in in velocity and if we assume that
every object has associated with its
some value here then we can start to
think about how these might connect so
one possibility is that for a given
force for a given force I can divide it
by its resistance to a change in
velocity so if it has a high resistance
to change in velocity if I'm dividing by
it then that will give me a low it will
actually give me a low velocity if I
have a low resistance to change in
velocity if I'm dividing by a low number
right over here then that will give me a
higher velocity and also the higher the
force or the larger the magnitude of the
force to larger the magnitude of the
velocity and they'll actually go in the
same direction so that's one possibility
the other possibility is I can take my
force my unbalanced force and maybe I
can divide it by this quantity M that's
associated with any given object which
its resistance to change in velocity but
that doesn't give me the velocity vector
maybe that gives me an acceleration
vector maybe that actually gives me the
rate of change of velocity and the rate
of change of velocity is going to go in
the same direction of the force and it's
going to be proportional to the magnet
the magnitude of the acceleration is
going to be proportional to the
magnitude of the force and maybe it'll
go in the same direction there's another
possibility that I introduced this idea
just to trick you maybe M has nothing to
do with it maybe maybe the acceleration
or the velocity are only going to be
dependent on what the velocity
he already was so maybe for a given
force I'm we doing that same color maybe
for a given force I am actually
dependent on what my existing velocity
is or maybe my existing speed and so if
I'm already at a high speed right over
here and I divide by a high speed I will
get a lower acceleration I will get a
lower I will get a lower acceleration if
I metal very low speed then I will get a
higher acceleration maybe it's the other
way around
maybe maybe for given force the higher
of my speed the higher my acceleration
and this looks like fancy notation but
this is just saying the magnitude of
velocity which is just my speed so I
take my force multiplied by my speed and
I'll just accelerate in that direction
and so the faster I go the faster the
faster I'm already going the faster I
will actually accelerate so I'll let you
think about which of these do you think
is actually the most consistent or the
or the one that is consistent with the
reality around us
so let's now try to think these through
and for these first two I'm gonna
imagine a scenario let's say I have a
truck it has a truck and let's say a
truck has a high resistance to a change
in velocity if you've ever tried to
change the velocity of a truck without
an engine so I have a truck right over
here I have a truck I have a truck right
over here and let's say it's travelling
it's travelling in this direction at a
is traveling it's velocity is a hundred
meter sec a hundred meters per second to
the right which is very very very fast
especially for this thing that has a
high resistance to change in velocity so
I'll just write high M high M right over
here and it's obviously it's obviously
going in that direction now let's
imagine that there's me and this truck
is right about to hit me but then I
press on this truck I apply a force to
the truck in the opposite direction so I
apply a force in the opposite direction
and let's say that that is a one Newton
force and you might not have a sense for
exactly how much one Newton is but let's
just say let me just tell you that that
is a force that I am capable of applying
to
a truck so I apply this force in that
direction just like that
well based on this this theory right
over here everything will be okay I will
not be hit by the truck because I'm
applying the force to the left this
formula right over here tells me that
the velocity of the object that I'm
applying the force to will immediately
take the direction of of my force the
force and the velocity have the same
direction so somewhat magically the
object the truck will just turn right
around it might not go very fast in the
other direction because this has a high
em but it'll immediately turn around
well that's not consistent with our
everyday reality we know no matter how
hard that I might push on that truck it
is still unlikely to stop much less
actually change direction so this is not
this right over here does not make a lot
of sense let's see if this one makes
sense for this scenario well this one it
tells us that I'm not going to actually
change the direction of the of the
object I'm not going to change the
velocity but I will accelerate it in the
same direction of my force so I applied
a force in that direction of 1 Newton
that tells me that I'm also going to
accelerate it in that direction if I'm
accelerating it in that direction right
over there so if I'm accelerating it to
the left so that's my acceleration if
I'm accelerating it to the left that
doesn't mean that all of a sudden the
truck is gonna start going to the left
it just means that its velocity is going
to start I guess one better way to think
about if the velocity is already going
to the right and I'm accelerating it to
the left the magnitude of the velocity
in the rightward direction is going to
get smaller or it's going to decelerate
which makes sense it might not
decelerate a lot because one Newton is
not a lot of force relative to a truck
but it might decelerate a very very very
minuscule amount and if I were apply a
large enough force or the larger my
force gets the more I might be able to
decelerate and if I was the Incredible
Hulk
maybe my force would be large enough to
decelerate it a good bit or maybe even
bring it to a halt so this actually does
not seem that inconsistent at least with
this scenario right here now let's think
about this one over here
maybe the higher the faster I was the
faster something is going the the less
of an impact the force will have on it
raishin but this starts to break down
when you think of the edge cases this
tells us that if my velocity is close to
zero so if I'm a very very very very
small velocity very very small speed
actually the magnitude of velocity is
very very very small then if I apply any
force I'll get a super high acceleration
I might get close to an infinite
acceleration especially as the velocity
close to zero in fact this whole formula
breaks down one of when the velocity is
zero when I'm at when I'm actually at
rest so this actually doesn't even
describe the at rest state so this does
not make sense and this one right over
here also breaks down at at rest it says
if the what if the magnitude the
velocity is zero I'm at rest then no
matter what the force is I will have no
acceleration because anything times zero
is going to be zero so this also this
also does not make sense and so this one
was consistent with what we experienced
every day is an action and the other
ones were pretty easy to get rid of and
this indeed is actually the case and you
might be more familiar with it if we
were to multiply both sides of this
formula or this equation by the quantity
M if I multiply both sides by M if I
multiply both sides by M right over here
then I get force force is equal to my
quantity M I'm just gonna swap the on
the left side these just cancel out on
the right side I get my quantity M
quantity M times acceleration I just
turned I just switched the order of this
so my quantity M times the acceleration
and we get quite possibly the most
famous formula in all of physics and
this is what Newton's second law tells
us now you might say hmmm that M all of
a sudden looks very very familiar it
probably looked familiar from the get-go
and if you're guessing that that M is
mass then you are absolutely correct M
is every object has a quantity
associated with it which is its mass
which is its resistance to change in
velocity and you might say well I
thought mat mass was how much stuff
there is how much I'll put stuff in
quotes how much stuff there is or how
much matter there is in our everyday
world that really is what mass is and
we'll see that that's still a different
thing and then weight but in our
everyday life how much stuff are how
much mass
is how we conceptualize mass but
especially as we get into kind of the
subatomic and the quantum scales Matt
how much stuff there is starts to not
make that much conceptual or intuitive
sense and so a pure definition for what
mass is actually is a resistance a
quantity that measures an object's
resistance to change in velocity